so basically fresh for fit guys it's a
podcast called fresh and fit on the
podcast they said that they're not into
dating black women two black dudes and
one of the dudes said it right there
they both they both said it yeah
so and basically let's start a lot of
controversy like shade room posted it a
bunch of other like specifically black
instagram
uh pages posted it yeah basically trying
to like cancel them more or less now
alex there's a black man that doesn't
date black women yeah what is what
what is your opinion so as a black and
spanish man who has dated black women in
the past
what you mean i've been in a
relationship but yeah um yeah i think
that's super corny of them to do that
but at the same time i can understand
having a type oh go so it's like if you
have a type
and
it sucks that racist part of that type
yeah but it's like hey you like what you
like but that's different than what the
he what was said what was said i don't
date black women it wasn't i have a type
well they have not type no no they have
uh they they started to say like you're
allowed to have types and like they're
tied in the conversation about like why
are women allowed to have standards but
they're not allowed to have sanders and
they said that they're not against it
they just don't
necessarily do it now i'm not trying to
cap for them but like that's what it
seemed like now what's interesting to me
is what dictates your type
you know i mean like there's a reason
why indian people like indian food
mexicans like mexican food right exactly
it's what you grow up with what you know
so what's happening to them yeah that
they're not attracted to the people that
look like them is that some [ __ ] you're
seeing on tv is that some [ __ ] that is
existing like in your life
you know is are there like parental
figures that are saying that this isn't
the ideal form of beauty something else
is you ever seen into the media
you could go there's people you ever see
the black guys that [ __ ] white girls but
yeah
it's really black girls don't [ __ ] them
interesting i think so it's some of that
sometimes we just what is it we eat what
we can hunt yeah yeah
yeah
the thing about how he knows how to hit
on a black girl he does not hit on a
white girl
right so he dates black girls because he
knows and it's like
it might be easier for them to date
white girls yeah and that really might
be what it is wanna hear what you said
specifically yeah go go play it what
about the black dating app called black
oh
it's funny i never used that one bro but
hey man i mean hey bro if you want a
date a bunch of shaniquas go for it man
laquisha yeah like
me and fresh aren't really down with the
brown like that we ain't night riders so
i'm good uh you know sometimes if
they're you know red bone but like in
general me and fresh uh don't dabble in
the dark if you know what i'm saying yep
um okay so last one guys uh
uh that stinks to me
i've tried a lot and been told to [ __ ]
off a lot
so because they're they're
they're projecting the image of alphas
aren't they i've seen a few of their
clips they're like we're the alpha guys
i'm in charge i do this yeah yeah yeah
and if anyone's ever taken that away
from you you would shun that because it
it would fracture your whole ego and
identity
i don't like [ __ ] black women what
the ones who don't want to [ __ ] you
anyway yeah they're irrelevant i didn't
want to
i i all these ones who are willing to
listen to me you know
that's a really interesting point you're
going to gravitate to the people that
make you feel how you want to feel about
yourself or the confirm what you already
do feel about yourself exactly and like
a white girl ain't going to look at you
back you ain't [ __ ] yeah
they the black one went white yeah they
don't know the difference between a
corny black guy and an actual alpha
black dude
i thought it was corny to say it
publicly just do it privately like alex
privately
but also it seems it seems like a cloud
chase like they are good at generating
headlines yeah and to agree we're giving
them more but it's just it was just
corny to me yeah like you also will
bring every black girl on your podcast
and then use headlines for the exact
girls they're saying you won't [ __ ]
right like you'll use them to get you
headlines and views and clicks right
when it comes to actually dating them
you won't do it it just it just felt
wack on every level yeah i've never had
a standard like that that's weird though
i've never had like a racial standard
per se i have
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know you just wouldn't
date white women no wouldn't date white
women i wanted very much to marry an
indian woman yeah for my own like to
pass on my own culture my own traditions
all that and i also thought it was kind
of whack and i used to be like i grew up
all around white girls in high school
that was the only hot girls i saw so i
was into that and then when i went to
college and met more indian girls i was
like okay they're beautiful i can do
this but it also just like yeah i could
do this i didn't know it's a possibility
because all you ever saw growing up was
indians you celebrated if you dated a
white girl like i've had indian guys
tell me i would pass on a beautiful
white girlfriend indian girl for an
average white girl and that [ __ ] blew my
mind and i was like that's gotta come
from somewhere and that's gotta stop
right like we can't keep doing yeah
where does that come from i think he
just wanted someone who spells thumb the
same way he said
[Laughter]
yo
[Laughter]
sometimes you see people dating you see
non-white people dating
much
uglier white girls than you believe that
they could get within their own race
well i think if i was white i would
always date interracially because you
always go up hmm
if i'm white there's no way i'm dating
no i'm dating up
interesting great looking black dudes
white girls you're just like really
and what do you think that is i see
white girls are indian dudes that are
you know definitely rich
yeah
but is that just some like internalized
racism it's i think we put them on a
pedestal
and that's part of also me joking around
saying white women are you know ugly
whatever they're i'm less attracted to
them generally but also it's like it's
so [ __ ] all you hear about is this
white girl so hot in this like they're
celebrated a lot so i'm just kind of
like contrarian do you feel that as a
white guy what that like white women's
beauty is celebrated a lot no but i'm
white living in america exactly yeah i
i actually probably notice non-white
women's beauty being celebrated far more
yeah that's because of the world you
live in no yeah you're in the
entertainment industry yeah like to a
lady person
no every model on the every cover of
everything until then
is a white woman yeah it's like i was
talking about this like i think it was
rock was saying something like that
about uh
like he doesn't want black uh he doesn't
want black superiority to be celebrated
he just wants black normalcy
to be celebrated like that's when the
racism is gone when you could just be
like the black doctor not the best ever
yeah doctor that happens to be black but
yeah maybe that's it i'm just not
noticing like all these mannequins or
whatever you made so i'm not listening
like all these like random models that
aren't even the top model yeah right i'm
just every single other model is just
some white girl yeah i'm noticing the
most famous
beautiful
minority chick yeah
interesting yeah yeah yeah brands will
point to that is like yo this is our
person this is our the one that broke
through and as a way to like defuse the
other issues within it interesting
yeah so that's how you see it now yeah
it just looks like there's a bunch of
models and they're all white and then
the exceptions to the rules exactly
and i'm just picking up exceptions no
the exceptions like we know like the
winnie harlows and the ones that like
she's both tyra banks and she's yeah
yeah
there's uh yeah okay okay okay okay but
it's like a status thing i think
so can you have a type
yeah but i think i think a big part of
what you like is
what you grew up around yeah so it's
like having a type is one thing saying i
don't have a type and they're like this
and it's based on the color of their
skin that's
actually racist yeah and it's it's sad
when somebody races toward their own
that's the saddest most broken [ __ ] yeah
i think adam might be on it bro yeah i
think you might be on it
hmm do you have a type adam
uh yeah about five foot seven
you hear me
adam's girl's outside
smart um
no not really really i i've only ever
been with white girls but i i think
that's probably more
you're like the fresh and fit of this
yeah i don't
i don't i feel like i'm so
white like i'm short fat and white yeah
and i feel like approaching
the
the black girls that would be attracted
to which would be really attractive
black hills yeah i think they'd look at
me like the [ __ ] is wrong who put you up
to this
[Laughter]
you can't possibly think this
conversation was gonna go well
[Applause]
you